one of the sort of most pressing and
important questions for the political
left and I guess really for Democrats to
to the extent that Democrats are a
possible representation of the actual
left instead of corporate interests
which is probably a debate we can have
in and of itself the question is what
kinds of candidates running as Democrats
would do well in the 2018 midterm and
even more generally this is a question
right and this gets asked of me often
during live calls we hear about it and
voicemails I get emails about it and the
question is usually framed as hey David
do you think Democrats are better off
running to the middle are they better
off running really progressive
candidates what is it that Democrats
should do and the answer is as is often
the case in the real world that there
isn't one answer the correct candidate
to take over a district held by a
corporate dem is going to be a different
candidate than the right candidate to
defeat a Republican incumbent for
example in a very red district versus a
blue district versus a swing district so
today I want to focus on swing districts
and there's actually a new study done by
Democratic pollster Celinda Lake and it
looked at 30 swing districts so we're
already narrowing the focus from how
should Democrats run in all elections to
how should they run in swing districts
and then from there the study only
looked specifically at 30 swing swing
districts and the idea was figure out in
those 30 swing districts what type of
Democratic candidate what types of ideas
would do best in an election and it's
very very common that pundits and
commentators will look at a swing
district they'll see roughly the same
percentage of registered Democrats and
Republicans and so they'll come away
saying listen that the best shot a
Democrat has is as a moderate Democrat
in order to win because you've got about
the same number of Democrats and
Republicans you're going to need to
appeal to some of both what the polling
done by Celinda Lake suggests is very
different there the polling that celinda
Lake has released suggests that
Democrats would do better in these swing
districts if they
to the left and the argument there is
that when you pull the voters in these
swing districts on issues and again that
doesn't mean just Republicans and
Democrats that also includes
independents they on average are to the
left of the average corporate Democrat
and certainly to the left of the average
Republican candidates so as an example
in these thirty swing districts the
voters polled by a seventy five percent
with a proportion of seventy five to 25
supported Medicare for all seventy five
percent support Medicare for all in a
swing district that would suggest that a
candidate who supports Medicare for all
would do better in that district
cracking down on Wall Street as another
example protecting Social Security and
Medicare there are lots of policies that
polled very well more than fifty percent
at minimum so why would a Democrat run
to the middle right the numbers seem to
very clearly suggest that actually
Democrats will be better off running
real progressives in these purple or
swing districts and more interesting is
that most of those thirty districts
where the polling took place currently
are held by Republican incumbents and
even still even though the voters in
recent elections voted for Republicans
these leftist policies had at minimum
fifty two percent support people saying
I'd be fifty two percent saying they'd
be more likely to support a candidate
with the progressive ideas only twenty
six percent saying they'd be less likely
to support that candidate so this seems
pretty clear cut and dry but there are
some caveats one caveat is this only
looked at 30 districts I've mentioned
that a couple times because I do think
it's important this strategy would not
necessarily work in every district and
that's why I think it's important not to
think about one strategy as these
strategy the other issue is that the
sample size was 600 to 900 generally
speaking if it's sampled correctly it's
a statistically significant sample but
you don't necessarily want to go around
making national strategy on the basis of
600 to 900 people in just 30 districts
but the main point is that trying to
thread the needle and being 1% to the
left of the incumbent be it a
Kratts or a Republican in a lot of
places it's a losing strategy especially
when generally speaking the candidate
who raises more money wins so if you've
got a corporate democrat or republican
incumbent and then a challenger that's
marginally to their left but can't raise
as much money more than likely to
candidate with more money is going to
win if you can at least separate from
just who can run more ads based on
fundraising and say hey here we have a
candidate that is actually more to the
left whose ideas actually seem to appeal
to more than 50% of the voters that
might even be a way to sort of dig into
the overwhelming advantage that the
candidate that has more money ultimately
has so very very interesting data not
necessarily something to develop a
national strategy around them no it's
interesting it seems like the third rail
for Democrats and these swing districts
it's it's not medicare-for-all or it's
not free college it tends to be abortion
it tends to be gun rights and those are
issues that even more centrist Democrats
are susceptible to losing voters over
yeah I'm not so sure I don't think you
know when we've talked to Bill Scherrer
he seems to think that the gun issue is
just not a voting issue and that it's
not really one that that's making a
difference I mean maybe maybe it's
helping to raise money or affecting
campaigns but I've not I've not seen
evidence of that that that guns is
really sort of a third rail issue in a
lot of these but it's interesting let's
see what the audience says I mean I
think my general perspective on this is
can it really get that much worse by
just running real progressives right
like the threading the needle with the
marginally more progressive candidate is
not working in a lot of places how much
worse can it really get to just say hey
we're gonna run some actual progressives
here and hopefully we'll see more of
this in the midterms coming up in just a
few months there's already primaries
where Democrats have choices between a
corporate Democrat and a more actual
progressive and we're gonna be following
how a lot of those primary elections go
the video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off
your membership